- Family, kindness
(audience clapping)
and a slew of new heartwarming
Hallmark Christmas movies
to enjoy from the comfort
of your own couch.
My first guests are the current Queens
of Hallmark Christmas.
First, please welcome Holly
Robinson Peete, everybody
(audience cheering)
(upbeat music)
I can't touch you.
Yo, yo, yo that's (laughing).
I was like, "Don't touch me."
- And you'd only just told
me that two seconds ago.
But then what did I do?
- I know, it's so odd though.
I know.
- We can't help it,
we're human beings.
- Claudine will be all over us.
So I literally was like,
No. I was like, yeah.
- No, no, I was like.
- But, hey everybody,
also we have via Skype,
Candace Cameron Bure and Lacey Chabert.
What's up, ladies?
(crowd cheering)
(upbeat music)
- I can't hug y'all either,
so don't come over here.
(Holly laughing)
Well, so you have all been making
Hallmark movies in Canada, right?
So how was it filming in?
- That's right.
I love Canada.
Where are you?
- We're in Vancouver,
mostly, I mean, we shoot
- Oh, I love.
in other places in Canada,
but the three of us,
I think I would say we shoot
most of our movies in Vancouver,
which for me is like when I was in my 20s
on 21 Jump Street.
That's where we were.
So every time I go back up there,
I try to pretend I'm 20
again, which I'm not.
- Oh my God, I don't wanna
be 20 again ever (laughing).
- Well, I wanna feel 20,
but I wanna know what
I know in my fifties.
But these ladies are just like,
it's so fun to go up there.
A little different this
time though, right ladies?
- 'Cause quarantine, yeah.
- Yeah, for sure I--
- Yeah. I'm actually
still in quarantine right now.
- So, I have two more days of quarantine,
but if I go a little bit stir-crazy.
It's actually been great,
'cause I'm quarantining
with Marilu Henner,
who plays my mom in my mystery movies.
So that part's super fun,
but it's very rainy and gray here.
And so I've been working
out a lot and there we are.
Yeah, we have a lot of fun together,
but I've been working out a lot
and there's a Peloton in this house
that we're staying in and
I got on for a workout
and had no idea what hit me,
but I bawled my eyes
out during this workout.
- Wait, because it was so
hard that you hated it?
- No, I love working out.
I love working out, but I think
it's just the gray up here
and missing my family
and being in quarantine,
you go a little stir-crazy.
And it was like this
flood of emotional relief,
which was great.
I felt a whole lot better after it.
- Oh my gosh.
That's an awesome release.
What about you, Lacey?
- Yeah, we've been up here
for about three months.
I did two Christmas movies
and now I'm onto the
"Crossword Mysteries".
I'm actually on set right now,
I'm in a basement (giggles)
talking to you guys.
- It's not creepy at all.
(audience laughing)
- No, it's like, this whole mystery vibe.
But I'm here with my husband and my sister
and my four-year-old daughter, Julia.
And so during quarantine
we were baking every recipe imaginable
and playing cards and hopscotch
and I mean, I've seen every
cartoon you can imagine.
And then I broke my toe
and I was getting ready
to do a dance movie.
So that was slightly unfortunate.
(Holly laughing)
- Oh my gosh.
- (mumbles) I feel so
happy to be back to work
and I love being in Vancouver.
Everyone here is so wonderful and kind
and I'm happy to be here.
- I love Canada.
I love, especially the...
- And they really
have it all together up
there when it comes to,
you know making it safe for us to shoot,
which has been pretty cool.
I quarantined with my three big sons.
I almost said something I can't say.
- [Host] Yeah(laughing).
- But my sons and my
husband and my two dogs.
So I brought everybody up.
- That's actually cool though.
- It was and it was really, it was cool.
And we actually did bond
and then got to break out
on my birthday and they joined gyms
and it was really, you
know, it was nice up there.
- Oh wow.
- And we talked, the three of us talked,
you know, along the way
because we share our stories
and leading these Hallmark movies
is such a blessing, the blessing of work
and the opportunity, but we bonded.
We've known each other
for a long, long time.
All three of us.
- That's so cool.
♪ Just hear those sleigh bells jingling ♪
- [Narrator] Your favorite
holiday tradition is back.
Hallmark Channel's Countdown to Christmas.
Get ready for a sleigh full
of holiday movies, 24/7
and all new original
holiday movie premieres
every Saturday and Sunday night at eight.
♪ Just hear those sleigh
bells jingling, ring ting ♪
- [Narrator] Join us for the
warmth and share more merry.
Countdown to Christmas, all season long.
Only on Hallmark Channel,
the heart of Christmas.
(audience cheering)
(whooshing)
- Welcome back, y'all.
That's a peek at some of
the latest Christmas movies
Hallmark has in store this season.
And I'm also here with
the ladies of Hallmark,
Holly Robinson Peete, Candace Cameron Bure
and Lacey Chabert.
Let's talk Hallmark, ladies.
How many hallmark Christmas
movies have y'all been in each?
- I've been in nine Christmas movies.
- Nine Christmas movies?
Oh my gosh.
- How many, Lacey?
- Ten.
- Oh my gosh.
- Oh ow.
- How many, Holly?
- And I'll round it out with eight.
- Oh my gosh.
That's a lot of movies.
Like, What do you--
- Yay us!
- I'm just gonna say that's amazing.
So here's my question
and I'll start with you, Holly.
What do you love about doing these movies?
Is it like, do you love, people
always ask me about my jobs
and it's, I love
genuinely who I work with.
Like and I think I'm at
an age where I'm like
I'm really not gonna go to work
unless that's the scenario.
Like, is it, do you love the crew
or it's always kind of a similar crew?
- I love the crew, I love the content.
I love the fact that
we're making joyful movies
at a time when people need to see that.
I love being able to force
my kids to watch something
with me in it on Christmas.
(Show host giggling)
I love to be able to just
be part of this whole
Hallmark magic and the
movies that we're making
and one of the movies,
"Christmas in Evergreen"
is this awesome, diverse,
mystical town in Vermont.
And I just think we're
doing some great things.
Candace and Lacey are two people
that I enjoy being part
of this whole brand.
So, I love it.
You know, it's just,
it's a total blessing.
- I love that.
All right, Lacey, I'll go to you next.
- Yeah, it's what Holly said.
You know, I'm happy and proud
and I feel like it's a real privilege
to be a part of something
that just brings joy
into people's living rooms
for a couple of hours.
And I know growing up my family and I,
we had our favorite Christmas movies
that we'd watch every year.
And so when someone tells me that,
you know a Hallmark movie is one of theirs
or one that I've been in, like, I just,
it makes me so happy.
It's an honor.
And I love that I can
watch them with my daughter
and I just love Christmas.
So it (giggling) only makes sense
that I enjoy making these movies.
- Me too girl, I love Christmas.
Candace, what about you?
- Holly, I wish my family would
sit down and watch my movies
like yours do with you,
(show host laughing)
but they're like, "I'm not
watching another Hallmark movie.
(Show host laughing)
"Let alone with you in it, mom, no."
But I love making these movies so much
because it brings so much joy to people.
Just what they said
like, this has become
people's holiday traditions
and they find so much
comfort in these movies.
And I'm so proud to be a part
of the Hallmark family
and the Hallmark brand.
This will be my 26th movie
with Hallmark channel.
- Oh my God, that's insane
(audience gasping)
and I'm telling you, my sister
and mother are those women.
They literally have seen every single one.
Like, every year they get so excited
like, "My Hallmark movies
are about to start up,"
and they're like so excited about it.
It's awesome.